Hallo und willkommen zurück zu den Denkerinnen
der Antike im Mittelalter Ich bin
Peter Adamson heute in dieser siebten
Vorlesung werden wir
ins 13. Jahrhundert
übergehen, als wir das letzte Mal im 12. Jahrhundert waren
und Heloise, die geliebte Studentin, betrachteten
Korrespondent von Abaelard und natürlich
Hildegard von Bingen und heute, da
wir uns ins 13. Jahrhundert bewegen, werden wir
uns zwei Figuren mit hohem Schaden und
zurück zum Mugdha-Buch ansehen, die
in gewisser Weise mit Hildegard von Bingen vergleichbar sind
dass sie beide
neue Mystiker sind und tatsächlich beide
erzählen, wie sie Visionen hatten, in denen
sie erlebten, wie Gott zu ihnen kam oder
Engel erlebte, und ähnlich wie
Hildegard, wenn auch nicht ganz so anweisend,
nicht ganz eine Struktur, wie sie
Ihnen die Vision geben werden und  dann werden sie
dir sagen, was es bedeutet, also
passiert hier etwas Ähnliches
wie bei Hildegard von Bingen, wo
Frauen eine Art Appell an die göttliche Autorität benutzen,
eine Art besondere Offenbarung
die sie erhalten haben, wenn Sie so wollen, und
das versetzt sie in eine
autoritative Position, die sie
normalerweise als Frauen nicht haben, weil
offensichtlich nicht nur jeder
eine Vision des Göttlichen genießen kann, sondern
andererseits, wenn sie es tun  Wenn wir
aus dieser visionären Rolle heraustreten, behaupten sie nicht, dass sie
völlig passiv sind oder sagen, „Sie finden
es heraus“, sondern sagen Ihnen tatsächlich,
was es bedeutet, bevor ich weiter
über diese beiden Figuren spreche. Ich
dachte, es wäre eine Idee, etwas zu sagen
über Mystik im Allgemeinen,
weil wir schließlich
viel Zeit damit verbringen, Mystiker zu betrachten, und das wird so
weitergehen, weil wir in einem anderen
Vortrag über Julian von Norwich sprechen werden
, der ein berühmter Mystiker des
späten 14. Jahrhunderts ist, und wir haben es getan
die Rabia schon aus dem islamischen
Kontext betrachtet und wie gesagt Hildegard und an
dieser Stelle haben wir wohl genug Mystik gesehen,
um ein paar allgemeine Dinge dazu zu sagen
und
vielleicht einige Krieger vorwegzunehmen, die manche
Zuschauer m  Wahrscheinlich
bin ich kein Philosoph, also arbeite ich in
philosophischen Fakultäten, und ich denke, es
wäre wahrscheinlich fair zu sagen, dass die meisten
Philosophen Mystik nicht
als Teil der Geschichte der Philosophie betrachten, und
wie ich bereits sagte, einer der Gründe, warum ich
Ich bezeichne diese gesamte Vortragsreihe
eher als Denkerinnen in der Antike im Mittelalter als als
Philosophinnen in der Antike im
Mittelalter, was ich zugeben muss, dass ich versucht war, das
zu tun, einer der Hauptgründe dafür
ist, dass ich es irgendwie verlassen wollte
offen und lassen Sie selbst entscheiden, ob Sie
denken, dass einige dieser mystischen
Angebote, über die wir berichten, tatsächlich Philosophen sind,
also denke ich, dass es dagegen
spricht, Mystiker als Philosophen zu sehen, ob
die Mystiker oder Männer oder Frauen so
etwas tun würden, könnten Sie sagen  Nun,
was ist Philosophie? Die große Frage an sich. Eine
philosophische Frage. Wir haben keine
Zeit, sie hier zu klären, aber sie hat
etwas mit der Verwendung rationaler Argumente zu tun.
Wir verwenden die Vernunft, um sie zu
beantworten  r bestimmte zentrale Fragen wie,
was ist Wissen, haben wir einen freien Willen,
existiert Gott und so weiter, beachten Sie,
dass die letzte Frage, existiert Gott, zeigt,
dass die Philosophie in das Terrain vordringen kann und dies auch tut,
das wir auch
als von Religion abgedeckt betrachten könnten  Wenn Sie
ein philosophisches Argument für oder
gegen die Existenz
Gottes vorbringen, betreten Sie sozusagen
theologischen Boden, aber die Art und Weise, wie Sie es
tun, ist philosophisch, weil Sie
der rein rationalen Argumentation
Recht geben,
Sie sind nicht ansprechend  zur Bibel oder zum
Koran oder zur Thora,
also wenn die Philosophie rein rational ist, dann
könnte ein Schritt weg von der Philosophie die
Theologie sein, in der rationale
Argumente verwendet werden, aber Sie
verwenden vielleicht Prämissen oder Ideen oder
Wahrheiten, von denen Sie behaupten, dass sie von einer
Offenbarung stammen  Quelle Dies ist ein sehr spezifischer
Begriff von Theologie, den ich Ihnen gerade gegeben
habe, der mit einer Figur
wie Thomas von Aquin verbunden ist, das ist genau das, was
er sagt, er ist übrigens ein
Conte  mporary der Zahlen
, über die heute gesprochen wird, huh divertimento
Denker des 13. Jahrhunderts, der glaubt, dass
Theologie in rationaler
Argumentation besteht, sehr ähnlich wie Philosophie,
aber als Prinzipien oder Prämissen
Wahrheiten verwendet, die aus der Bibel stammen, also Dinge, die
Sie nur durch Offenbarung wissen würden, so dass
Sie zum Beispiel in der Lage sein könnten  Wenn man
philosophisch so etwas wie "Ich habe eine Seele"
oder "Körper kann
im Prinzip unendlich geteilt werden, aber man kann mit
Vernunft oder philosophischen Argumenten wissen, dass
Gott eine Dreifaltigkeit ist, könnte man vielleicht
beweisen, dass er existiert, aber er wäre nicht in der
Lage zu beweisen  beweisen, dass er eine Dreieinigkeit ist,
aber sobald Ihnen in der Bibel gesagt wird,
dass er eine Dreieinigkeit ist oder dass er
als Jesus Christus inkarniert wurde
, können Sie wieder
philosophisch argumentieren, um herauszufinden,
was es bedeuten könnte, zu sagen, dass er an
der ist  Trinität,
er ist eine Trinität, finde heraus, was es
bedeuten könnte zu sagen, dass er inkarniert war und
so weiter, also ist das Theologie, also gibt es eine
Art Appell an Glauben und Offenbarung  n,
aber du handelst immer noch auf
ausgesprochen rationale Weise, du argumentierst immer noch
mit anderen Worten, also sagen wir
einfach um der Argumentation willen,
dass das die Theologie ist, es gibt andere
Arten, über Theologie nachzudenken, aber wenn
das so weit richtig ist, dann haben wir'  Wir haben Philosophie,
rein rationale Theologie, eine Art Mischung
aus Vernunft und Glauben, und dann so weit
weg von der Philosophie, wie
Sie vielleicht denken, wäre Mystik,
weil Mystik wohl eine
Annäherung an Gott oder vielleicht die ganze
Existenz ist, aber in dieser Tradition sind wir
Das Betrachten ist normalerweise Gott, es ist eine
Annäherung an Gott, die sich der Vernunft zu entledigen scheint,
so dass Sie die Idee haben
, sich rein auf die Erfahrung zu berufen, rein auf
eine Vision von Gott, die keine rationale Argumentation beinhaltet, die
wahrscheinlich nicht
einmal etwas anspricht, was der Nicht-
Mystiker anspricht  Ich könnte es schätzen, Mystiker
werden sagen, gut, wenn Sie diese mystische Vision nicht so erlebt haben
wie ich, dann
können Sie unmöglich hoffen, sie zu verstehen,
ich könnte eine Art o haben  Ich
mag den Zugang zu einer Erfahrung, die andere
Menschen nicht haben, und so weiter. Ich denke
, das ist ein Grund, warum Philosophen
Mystik nicht als Teil dieses Baums
der Philosophie betrachten, und ein weiterer Grund ist
vielleicht einfach die Art und Weise, wie mystische
Texte oft sind  Sie sind oft so poetisch geschrieben, dass
sie oft voller Metaphern sind.
Sie beinhalten oft die Verwendung oder das Erzählen
persönlicher Erfahrungen, wie
Hildegard es getan hat und wie
wir heute Mexiko sehen werden, dann Honda, was es tat,
und dies ist das Gegenteil davon
Die Art, wie die Philosophen schreiben, ist
sehr distanziert, objektiv, ohne
so viel Investition und vor allem
sehr streng, also sagst du genau
das, was du meinst, du schreibst nicht in Gedichten,
wenn du Philosophie machst, okay,
so wie ich es getan habe  Sie
ahnen wahrscheinlich schon, dass
ich jetzt sagen werde, dass ich damit nicht ganz einverstanden bin,
und tatsächlich gibt es
viele Arten, in denen ich dem, was
ich gerade gesagt habe, wieder nicht zustimme  vielleicht kann ich nicht gehen
i  In der ganzen Zeit, die wir haben, aber um
nur mit dem letzten Punkt zu beginnen, ist
es einfach nicht wahr, dass
Philosophen nicht persönliche
Erfahrungen verwenden, sie verwenden oft
Metaphern, wie sie oft Gedichte verwenden, denken Sie nur
an Platon  Viele Leute
würden sagen, dass er der größte Philosoph
ist, der je gelebt hat. Er verwendet ständig Metaphern,
und tatsächlich ist eine seiner berühmtesten
Passagen in der Republik eine große
Metapher, die sich vorstellt, dass diese Menschen
in einer Höhle angekettet waren und können.  Sie können
Ihre Realität nicht so sehen, wie sie ist, weil sie denken,
dass die Schatten an der Wand vor
ihnen die realen Dinge sind, während
tatsächlich die realen Dinge
außerhalb der Höhle ähnlich sind, wenn
Mystiker wirklich versuchen, unsere Aufmerksamkeit
auf etwas zu lenken, das jenseits des normalen
rationalen Diskurses liegt  das
haben philosophen auch oft gemacht nicht
alle philosophen aber wenn man
erstmal im nacken und in der antike bleibt wenn
man zum beispiel an die neuplatoniker denkt
sind die oft sa  id in gewissem
Sinne mystisch,
gerade weil sie denken, dass
es eine Art von Prinzipien gibt, die
jenseits dessen liegen, was wir mit normaler Sprache sagen können,
was wir mit der Vernunft erfassen können,
aber so ziemlich jeder stimmt zu, dass
sie Teil der Geschichte der
Philosophie sind und  Ein Grund dafür ist meiner
Meinung nach, dass sie die Grenzen
zwischen dem, was man mit Vernunft tun kann, und dem,
was man nicht tun kann, sehr sorgfältig abstecken, und ich
denke tatsächlich, dass dies für
sozusagen rein mystische Autoren gilt, wie
die, die wir uns angesehen haben  In
den letzten paar Vorträgen und die
wir uns jetzt
ansehen, sagen sie offensichtlich nicht, dass die Vernunft
nichts erreichen kann,
und in der Tat, hoch Tillich, der einer
der beiden Autoren ist, über die sie diskutieren wollte
, spricht viel über a  Vernunft und
lobt sie sehr, deshalb denkt sie,
dass die Vernunft ein sehr wichtiger Teil
des religiösen Lebens ist, und sogar des mystischen
Lebens glaubt sie einfach nicht, dass die Vernunft
ihre Ressourcen erschöpft, die uns zur Verfügung
stehen  Wenn wir uns Gott nähern, wird sie
grob gesagt sagen,
dass die Vernunft mit dem ergänzt
werden muss, was sie Liebe nennt, indem sie die
Wortbedeutung verwendet, auf die wir zurückkommen werden, also
denke ich eigentlich, dass Mystik nicht so
sehr eine Konkurrenz zur Philosophie ist  oder eine
Alternative zur Philosophie, aber in gewisser
Weise als charakteristisches philosophisches
Genre, das sich der Grenzen bewusst ist
, die wir als Philosophen
oder sogar als Menschen haben, sodass sie versuchen,
die Grenze zwischen dem, was
wir sagen können, und dem, was
wir nicht sagen können, zu artikulieren  und dann versuchen sie
, uns darüber hinaus Ressourcen für den
Zugriff auf das zu geben, was über das
hinausgeht, was wir können, über das hinaus, was wir sagen
oder über das hinausgehen können, was wir über die
Verwendung normaler rationaler Techniken
denken können, also
wäre es zu weit, Mystik als reinen Rationalismus zu betrachten  simpel
eigentlich haben wir hier eine Art
Theorie, wenn Sie so wollen, die Vernunft einschließt
und dann unsere Vernunft mit
etwas ergänzt, das über die Vernunft hinausgeht, okay
, das ist also ein Grund  Sohn, über Mystik nachzudenken,
ist irgendwie philosophisch.
Ich denke, was ich hier zu sagen versuche,
ist, dass der eigentliche Akt des Schreibens auf
mystische Weise oder das Artikulieren eines Bedürfnisses nach
mystischer Erfahrung bereits
philosophische Voraussetzungen hat und
voller philosophischer Verpflichtungen ist
Außerdem denke ich, dass es
mindestens zwei andere Arten gibt, in denen Mystik
einen tiefen philosophischen Kern hat. Eine
davon ist grob gesagt metaphysisch.
Was ich damit meine, ist, dass Mystiker,
insbesondere mittelalterliche Mystiker, an
eine Ursache denken, wenn sie an Gott denken
die alle Dinge kommen, die
notwendigerweise den Auswirkungen dieser Ursache überlegen sind.
Die Idee hier wäre ungefähr
so und wenn Sie dies tatsächlich in Thomas von
quin finden, wenn Sie ve
suchen, Wärme zu erklären, könnten Si
sich irgendwie umsehen und es versuchen
Finden Sie heraus, was die Ursache für Hitze ist,
dann denken Sie vielleicht, na ja, hier ist mein
Herd, mein Herd ist heiß, er bewirkt, dass meine
Pizza warm wird, also macht er meinen Piz  za
seltsam, aber es gibt Dinge, die heißer sind
als mein Ofen, also gibt es etwas
, das am heißesten ist, ist irgendwie höchst
seltsam, das Prinzip der Hitze, das die
Ursache aller Hitze ist, und Thomas von Aquin denkt ja,
und die Antwort ist Feuer, also ist Feuer am
heißesten  Etwas, das es in der aristotelischen
Physik gibt, und es bewirkt, dass alles
andere heiß wird, indem es darin vorhanden ist. Sagen wir einfach
um der Argumentation willen, dass es wahr ist, dass
sie nicht
so sehr Wärme verursachen, der
Punkt ist, dass Ursachen im Allgemeinen
paradigmatisch sind  und irgendwie
transzendent die Eigenschaften, die sie
in anderen Dingen verursachen,
jetzt wird der Mystiker sagen, dass, wenn
Sie diese Idee auf die Spitze treiben
, Sie sehen, dass Gott als Ursache von
allem vielleicht in gewissem Sinne derselbe sein muss
wie die Dinge, die  er bewirkt, dass er zum
Beispiel ein Wesen sein könnte, weil er
bewirkt, dass Dinge existieren,
er könnte Einheit haben, weil er bewirkt, dass
Dinge Einheit haben, er kann gut sein,
weil er Dinge gut macht,
indem er sie erschafft, aber zusätzlich  Genauso wie
Feuer transzendent heiß ist, ist es so heiß
, dass andere Dinge nicht heiß sein können, also
könnte Gott diese Eigenschaften auf eine Weise haben
, die über jede andere Manifestation
dieser Eigenschaft hinausgeht, die wir sehen können, und so
gibt es hier eine Art Spannung, wenn Sie
denken  über ursachen und wirkungen auf diese
weise, einerseits muss die
ursache etwas mit ihren wirkungen teilen,
andererseits muss sie von
ihren wirkungen verschieden sein, sie muss
den wirkungen in der hinsicht, in
der sie verursacht, irgendwie voraus sein  Effekte zu erzielen,
und was der Mystiker natürlich
tun wird, ist, dass sie die
Ähnlichkeit abschwächen und die Unähnlichkeit betonen werden,
sie werden sagen, dass
Gott jenseits unserer Erfahrung ist, jenseits
der Eigenschaften der Dinge, die wir
um uns herum sehen  und wenn wir zum Beispiel bereit sind zu sagen,
dass Gott ein Wesen ist oder dass
Gott gut ist, sollten wir bereit sein
zuzugeben, dass Gottes Wesen und Güte
unser Fassungsvermögen übersteigt, und wenn wir bereit sind, das
zu sagen, und eigentlich fast alles
Mittelalterliche Menschen würden gerne sagen, dass
alle mittelalterlichen Philosophen und
Theologen einen Weg brauchen werden
, um zu Gott zu gelangen, wenn wir ihn wirklich
vollständig oder zumindest so vollständig wie möglich erfassen wollen,
also ist das im Grunde das
metaphysische Argument für die Notwendigkeit  Für eine
mystische Erfahrung sage ich effektiv
, dass es ein gutes
metaphysisches Argument für Gottes
Transzendenz gibt, und wenn Gott wirklich
transzendent ist, dann können wir nicht einfach so
über ihn denken, wie wir
vielleicht über Feuer oder andere Dinge denken
dass wir in der geschaffenen Welt
um uns herum sehen können, dass wir eine
besondere Art und Weise brauchen werden, um einen Saum zu bekommen,
der natürlich eine Offenbarung sein könnte, und das ist
effektiv das, was die Theologen
tun, sie wenden sich der Offenbarung zu
, um sie zu ergänzen  menschliche Vernunft, wie ich
über Aquin gesagt habe, der Mystiker hat ihr
eigenes Offenbarungsrecht, dass sie diese
besondere Erfahrung haben, die es ihnen ermöglicht,
auf eine Weise auf Gott zuzugreifen, die normalerweise
für Menschen unmöglich wäre  Das ist eine
Art von philosophischer Grundlage für
Mystik. Eine andere philosophische Grundlage
würde ich ungefähr epistemisch nennen,
also ist der Gedanke hier, dass
es nur einige Dinge gibt, die
wir nicht wissen können, und vielleicht ist es schwierig
, genau zu erklären, was wir nicht
wissen können  oder kann nicht sprechen, weil es
per definitionem unaussprechlich ist,
aber ich nehme an, dass der Mystiker sagen könnte,
dass die Last in gewisser Weise auf der
Person des Philosophen liegt, der denkt, dass
wir alles verstehen können, um zu erklären,
wie alles erkannt werden kann und
insbesondere wie  Gott kann bekannt sein, und hier
ist eine Art aristotelisches Argument für
diese Idee, dass Sie wahrscheinlich kein
animistisches wie heißes Bild finden würden
, sondern von jemandem wie Thomas von Aquin sympathisch aufgenommen würden
sie, indem Sie
Erklärungen finden, also denken Sie wieder an die Pizza
im Ofen, warum ist sie heiß, weil
der Ofen heiß ist und der Ofen
sie aufwärmt, also, wenn wir es versuchen  g
Um Phänomene zu verstehen, zeigen wir auf die
Ursache, um sie zu erklären. Dies ist eine ähnliche
Idee wie das, was wir gerade betrachtet haben, aber
denken Sie jetzt vom Standpunkt
unseres Wissens darüber nach. Wenn wir etwas haben
, das keine Ursache hat, dann gibt es keine weitere
Erklärung  Es gibt keinen Sinn, in dem wir
es nie vollständig verstehen werden, so dass Sie
etwas vollständig verstehen können, für das
Sie eine vollständige kausale Erklärung gegeben haben,
aber etwas, das keine Ursache hat, ist
etwas, für das Sie keine
vollständige Kostenrechnung geben können, und so Sie  Ich werde es
nie verstehen, es ist nicht
ganz so, wie Philosophen es vielleicht
wollen, also ist das
sogar in Tunnel zwei der aristotelischen
Philosophie eine Art Argument dafür, warum Gott zumindest
bis zu einem gewissen Grad unerkennbar sein könnte, und das
eröffnet wiederum Raum für Forderungen oder zumindest
auf andere Weisen zu hoffen, Gott
zu erkennen, die einem als Philosophen nicht offenstehen,
und das ist etwas, für
das viele Theologen des
Mittelalters, nicht zuletzt Thomas von Aquin,
und die Mystiker sensibel waren  Daher sind sie dem
, was die Theologen
und Philosophen dort tun, nicht völlig fremd. Wenn
überhaupt, würde ich sagen, dass ich nur
diese Wege hervorhebe, auf denen Gott die
Grenzen unserer Sprache und unseres Denkens überschreiten könnte, und
dann einen alternativen Weg zu
Gott anbieten, das sind also nur einige wenige
allgemeine Gedanken über Mystik und
natürlich das, was ich gerade gesagt habe,
könnte auf fast jeden Mystiker zutreffen, also
könnte es auf eine Idee zutreffen, die auf
Hildegard hi de vich Mack Toad Julian von
Norwich zutreffen könnte, offensichtlich befassen wir uns
besonders mit Frauen  Mystiker und so wäre es
vielleicht ein paar Worte wert, was die
Leute über die besondere
Stellung von Mystikerinnen gedacht haben und ob das,
was sie gedacht haben, gerechtfertigt ist, also
werde ich Ihnen wieder eine Art Geschichte geben und
sie dann so kritisieren  Hier ist die
Geschichte
Manchmal stellen Menschen zwei Arten von
Mystik gegenüber, man könnte sie
kontemplative Mystik und effektive
Mystik nennen, also wäre kontemplative
Mystik als Wort das
philosophischere  Jede Art von Mystik,
also wäre es Mystik, die eher
wie ein theologischer Text aussieht, vielleicht könnte sie
tatsächlich Argumente enthalten und es
wäre eine Art, Konzepte auf
irgendeine Weise zu analysieren oder vielleicht Analogien zu
anderen Dingen zu ziehen, die wir verstehen, indem wir
Metaphern verwenden, um sie auszudrücken  wie Gott sein könnte,
und das bekommt man
ziemlich oft in einem anderen
Autor aus dem 13. Jahrhundert.  Bonaventura, also ist er jemand
, der sehr vertraut ist mit der
aristotelischen Philosophie und der gesamten
philosophischen Tradition, aber er hat auch
einen
Aspekt seiner Philosophie, der sehr vermisst wird, aber ich
denke, das würde unter das fallen, was die Leute
normalerweise als kontemplative Mystik bezeichnen, also ist
es sehr artikuliert und sein wirklicher
Versuch, was zu analysieren  Es könnte sein,
über etwas nachzudenken, das außerhalb unseres
normalen Denkbereichs liegt, dann gibt es
effektive Mystik, eine effektive
Mystik, anstatt sich nach
außen zu wenden, über die Grenzen unseres Denkens
und unserer Sprache hinauszugehen und die Grenzen
unseres Denkens und unserer Sprache zu verschieben,
wendet sich effektive Mystik wohl nach innen  es
sucht Gott in intimen Erfahrungen, die
das Individuum hat, wie Emotionen
oder Visionen, also haben Sie hier eine viel
konkretere Sprache, Sie haben die
Metaphern, wenn es überhaupt Metaphern
gibt, werden sehr konkret sein, also denken Sie daran, dass Sie
wissen, dass Hildegard über einen Mann
aus Licht spricht  oder ein Berg und so weiter, diese
konkreten Bilder oder Dinge  Dass sie es
buchstäblich erlebt, erzählt sie uns, und
das ist der affektive Teil, und dann tritt sie davon
weg, es beginnt zu
kommentieren, was es bedeutet, vielleicht geraten
wir da eher in etwas
wie kontemplative Mystik, also
könntest du das Gleiche erleben  und
wir könnten
bis zu einem gewissen Grad beide Dinge im selben Autor ablaufen lassen, nein, wie Sie
sich vorstellen können, ist es oft so, dass die
Menschen weibliche Mystiker im
Mittelalter mit effektiver Mystik in Verbindung bringen
, weil sie glauben, dass Frauen
vielleicht emotionaler sind, vielleicht sind sie mehr  passiv,
sie sind weniger artikuliert, sie sind
weniger gebildet, also ist die Mystikerin
jemand, der eine Gotteserfahrung
wie eine individuelle Begegnung mit Gott hat,
und das wird oft, wie wir sehen werden
, in erotischen Begriffen ausgedrückt, also hat sie
eine Art  von Sehnsucht oder Verlangen nach Gott
direkt hat sie eine erfüllte Begegnung
mit Gott, die in gewisser Weise
mit einer sexuellen Begegnung vergleichbar sein könnte, und
das ist etwas, was wir nicht erwarten
würden  und natürlich denken wir auch an dich,
also haben wir eine Art trockenere philosophische
Mystik, das ist die
kontemplative Mystik, und dann haben wir
diese emotionale Art von überhitzter, sehr
konkreter Mystik, die effektive
Mystik ist, und die Leute würden das
dann mit Frauen etwas anderes
assoziieren  An dieser Stelle sollte darauf hingewiesen werden,
dass sich die Mystik im Fall des
effektiven Mystikers tatsächlich
buchstäblich auf der Ebene des
Körpers manifestieren könnte, so dass sie zum Beispiel aufhören
könnten zu heizen, sie könnten zum Beispiel
Zeichen auf ihrem Körper zeigen, die irgendwie
Gott wie begegnen  Sie könnten blutige
Wunden bekommen und so weiter, also würde ich sagen,
dass dies eine sehr geschlechtsspezifische Art zu lesen ist,
eine offensichtlich sehr geschlechtsspezifische Art
, die Geschichte der mittelalterlichen
Mystik zu lesen, und ich denke, dass es
grundlegend falsch ist, nicht wegen all der
Dinge, über die ich gerade gesprochen habe  in einer festlich
begangenen wirkungsvollen Mystik
fehlt die weibliche Mystik, sondern weil
sie bei der männlichen vorhanden ist  Mystiker zum
Beispiel haben wir eine Figur wie Bernhard von
Clairvaux, den ich letztes Mal erwähnt habe.
Er ist der wichtige Theologe, der geholfen hat
, die Kreuzzüge zu starten, an die Hildegard
diesen Brief geschrieben hat, aus dem ich gelesen habe, und
es gab tatsächlich eine Menge
effektiver Mystik in Bernhards Werken
und  auch viel erotische Sprache, und
er ist nur ein Beispiel. Wenn Sie also
die Geschichte der Mystik dieser
Männer und Frauen im Mittelalter durchgehen, werden
Sie sehen, dass die effektive Mystik schon damals
da war und tatsächlich
im 13. Jahrhundert und dann
besonders zunahm  im 14. Jahrhundert, und Sie werden
sowohl Männer als auch Frauen sehen, die
zwischen kontemplativen und effektiven
Modi oszillieren. Ein gutes Beispiel dafür könnte
der Theologe John Cassell aus dem 14. Jahrhundert sein,
der ein Zeitgenosse von Julian von
Norwich ist und selbst so etwas zu sein scheint
hin- und hergerissen zwischen dem Versuch,
auf theologischer Art und Weise über Mystik zu schreiben, und
auf einer persönlicheren,
emotionaleren Art und Weise, also ist er sowohl ein
kontemplativer als auch  und ein effektiver
Mystiker, wie ich bereits angedeutet habe. Ich denke
, das gilt auch für die heilige Kunst, und ich
denke, es gilt bis zu einem gewissen Grad auch für
Haida vich und Nested aus Magdeburg, über die
wir jetzt sprechen werden, obwohl sie es tun
würden  normalerweise
als eine Art Heldin mit aufgesetzter Mystik klassifiziert werden,
okay, das
reicht als Einführung. Ich möchte nur
eine andere Sache erwähnen, die es wirklich wert ist, erwähnt
zu werden, und ich war sowohl für
Irish als auch für Metal richtig, und das ist, dass keines
von beidem zutrifft  schrieb in schwarzer Höhe von es ist
aus Belgien, also das ist übrigens eine
Sache, die ich glaube, ich sage in der Podcast-
Episode über sie meine Podcast-Serie.
Sie ist eine gute Antwort auf die Trivia-
Frage. Können Sie mir eine interessante
Figur aus der Geschichte nennen von  philosophie
wer ist aus belgien ein
anderer guter fragt wo wir irgendwie
dagegen sind übrigens ein anderer
denker des 13. jahrhunderts aber hohe stimme kommt
wahrscheinlich aus antwerpen wir sind uns nicht ganz
sicher wir sind uns auch nicht ganz sicher was ihre
daten angeht aber s  Er schreibt in mittelalterlichem Holländisch,
also kommt sie aus der Gegend von Belgien,
beschenkt kommt aus Deutschland, und sie schreibt
in mittelalterlichem Deutsch, wir haben tatsächlich
nicht die Originalversion ihres Buches,
das das fließende Licht Gottes
oder der Gottheit heißt, weil es verloren gegangen ist
Stattdessen haben wir eine spätere mittelalterliche,
aber immer noch deutsche Übersetzung. Was wir also
haben, ist im Grunde eine Übersetzung,
die in der nächsten Stufe des mittelalterlichen
Deutsch geschrieben wurde, von dem, was sie geschrieben hätte,
also gibt es vermutlich ziemlich nahe an dem,
was sie geschrieben hat, also ist das wichtig,
weil  Wir sehen diese beiden Figuren
als Teil eines allgemeinen Trends in der
mittelalterlichen Literatur, wo
Umgangssprachen, also nicht Lachen, im
Grunde immer mehr in das geistige Leben
eintreten. Das heißt sicherlich nicht,
dass die Leute an den Universitäten aufgehört haben, Latein zu
schreiben  bis ins 14.
jahrhundert hinein und natürlich
bis in die renaissance schreiben die leute immer noch
lateinisch, es bleibt immer noch die
elitäre diskurssprache, es ist die
lang  Wissenschaft ist gewissermaßen die Sprache
der Philosophie, aber
wir haben immer mehr Intellektuelle, die
in
Volkssprachen schreiben, wie
z  Französisch und hier haben wir Niederländisch und
Deutsch, also haben wir eine ziemlich große Auswahl
an mittelalterlichen Umgangssprachen
, die verwendet werden, um diese Fragen der
Mystik, Theologie und sogar Philosophie anzugehen.
Ich denke, es wäre fair zu sagen,
dass es eine ziemlich enge Verbindung zwischen gibt
Tatsache, dass unsere Figuren Frauen sind
und dass sie in Landessprachen schreiben,
weil Frauen, wie ich letztes Mal erwähnte,
einfach nicht die gleichen
Bildungschancen hatten wie Männer, ein klassischer
Weg, Latein zu lernen, wäre
natürlich hinfällig  Zur Universität zu gehen und Geisteswissenschaften zu
studieren ist nicht so, als ob die Menschen im Mittelalter
Latein als Muttersprache sprachen,
das ist eine antike Sprache mit der
Genauso ist es bei uns, aber sie gehen
als Kinder zur Universität, als junge
Teenager lernen sie Latein zu schreiben und zu lesen,
und dann schreiben sie in dieser nützlichen
Sprache, wie ich sage, wenn Sie nicht an
einer Universität waren, können Sie das  Sie können nicht
auf Latein schreiben, es sei denn, Sie sind darin geschult,
wie es zum Beispiel Hildegard war, und
Sie haben auch nicht unbedingt Zugriff
auf die gesamte Palette lateinischer Literatur, die
einige der Figuren betrachten wollten
Wahrscheinlich haben sie Latein gelesen, aber
sie haben nicht laut geschrieben, und die Tatsache,
dass sie die Umgangssprache schreiben, und
die Tatsache, dass ihre Frauen
in den
Köpfen ihrer Zuhörer sehr natürlich zusammenpassen würden, ist eigentlich ein gutes Zeichen dafür,
dass dies etwas ist, was wir tun  lesen kann
und Dante am Anfang des
nächsten schrieb er ein Werk auf Italienisch, in dem er
ausdrücklich sagt, dass er
einige seiner philosophischen Einsichten in dieser
Umgangssprache anbietet, weil er versucht
, ein breiteres Publikum zu erreichen,
also keine intellektuellen Männer, sondern ein
breiteres Publikum  Adhership, von dem er ausdrücklich sagt, dass es
Frauen einschließt, und es gibt andere
Beispiele dafür, zum Beispiel gibt es
Übersetzungen wissenschaftlicher Werke in die
Umgangssprachen, sogar ein Werk über
Gynäkologie, also Medizin für Frauen, es gibt
ein Beispiel dafür, wo wir eine
Übersetzung eines lateinischen gynäkologischen
Werks haben  die entspannte Anziehungskraft, und der
Übersetzer sagt, der Grund, warum ich dies in die
Volkssprache übersetze, ist,
dass Frauen es lesen können, damit der allgemeine
Trend der Vernakularisierung des
Diskurses im späteren Mittelalter im
Gegensatz zum frühen Mittelalter
etwas ist  Sie können sich wirklich
mit der Präsenz von Frauen in diesen
eher intellektuellen
Diskursregistern identifizieren, und ich denke, es ist keine
Überraschung, dass wir im späteren
Mittelalter, wo wir mehr zufällige
einheimische Literatur haben, auch
mehr Frauenfiguren haben, also haben wir wirklich angefangen
Mit dem zwölften Jahrhundert, das
schon ziemlich weit ins
Mittelalter hineinreicht, hätten wir ein paar
Frauen erwähnen können  de Wer waren die, die seit dem
frühen Mittelalter bekannt sind, aber die meisten
der großen Autorinnen des
Mittelalters sind im 14. Jahrhundert oder in der
Mitte des 13. Jahrhunderts bis ins
14. Jahrhundert okay, soviel zur
Einführung, lassen Sie uns jetzt weitermachen  on to height
image who is si ist eine belgische mystikerin aus
der mitte des 13. jahrhunderts wir haben unsere
ganze palette an werken von ihr wir haben eine reihe von
briefen wir haben eine reihe von visionen
ähnlich wie die von hildegard, aber wie gesagt, sie sind
nicht annähernd so  so strukturiert, wo Sie
die Art von Vision haben, die in einer
Darstellung oder Interpretation der
Vision dargelegt wird, wie sie verlaufen,
es ist flüssiger, und oft sind diese
Texte kürzer als Hildegards
Visionen, also haben wir Buchstaben, wir haben
Visionen und dann haben wir Kämme  und die
Themen, für die sie bekannt ist, ziehen sich irgendwie
durch all diese verschiedenen Genres,
obwohl die Briefe uns mehr
über ihr persönliches Leben erzählen als die Gedichte
oder die Visionen, die Sie vielleicht erwarten würden,
einschließlich derer, die sie anscheinend hatte
etwas widersprüchliche Beziehungen zu
ihren Backkollegen,
was ist das, werden Sie fragen, also
muss ich Ihnen hier etwas über die
Art von sozialer Bewegung erzählen, zu der sowohl das
Meta- als auch das HUD-Bild gehörten, nämlich die
Bigge-Bewegung, also waren die großen Gene
Frauen, die ihr Leben gewidmet haben  Für die
Spiritualität wie Nonnen haben sie nicht
wie Nonnen geheiratet, aber entscheidend ist, dass sie
keine Gelübde auf die Art und Weise abgelegt haben,
dass man sich vorstellen kann, dass man
wie eine Nonne ist, aber billig
in dem Sinne, dass man nicht verspricht,
zu bleiben  unverheiratet und für
den Rest deines Lebens keusch bleiben du bist
dir selbst und einem Kloster nicht nah, du
trittst einer Gemeinschaft von Frauen bei, die praktisch
wie Nonnen leben, ohne Nonnen zu sein, und
so eine Art Grauzone
zwischen Normalität einnehmen  Frauen und Nonnen, also
Frauen, die aus mittelalterlicher Sicht Teil des normalen gesellschaftlichen Lebens der Ehe sind,
und Nonnen, die
von diesem Tag völlig entfernt sind und daher in
dieser Arbeit an die mittelalterliche min  d
vielleicht etwas beunruhigenden Raum, weil
sie immer noch das Potenzial haben,
mit Männern umzugehen, waren sie manchmal
im Handelsbereich tätig, so dass die Anfänge
dazu neigten, Geld im
Textilhandel zu verdienen, um ihre Organisation am Laufen zu halten,
also hatten sie es mit zu
vielen Leuten zu tun, die sie waren
nicht so versteckt wie Nonnen und
doch lebten sie wie Nonnen und dies
wurde von der Kirche zunächst mit einiger Nervosität begrüßt
, dann aber früh im
13. Jahrhundert zugelassen und die Unruhe darüber wuchs
bis zu dem Punkt, an dem die große Bewegung war
in einem 14. Jahrhundert im Grunde unterdrückt,
so befinden wir uns jetzt hier in der Mitte des
13. Jahrhunderts in der Blütezeit der
Beginenbewegung, der die beiden hi, die
ich getroffen habe, immer noch angehören und das ist offensichtlich
der Kontext, in dem sie
so arbeiten  Wir sehen uns hier
extrem spirituelle Frauen an, die
sich einem Leben verpflichtet haben,
das Gott sehr gewidmet ist, wie es eine Nonne tun würde,
und wenn Sie darüber nachdenken, was das
besonders bedeuten würde  o Mittelalterlich
bedeutet dies, dass sie
die Option, einen Menschen zu heiraten, abgelehnt
haben und sich
stattdessen Gott oder Christus hingeben oder sich Gott oder Christus widmen, und
so macht es eigentlich vollkommen Sinn, dass
ein grundlegendes Thema in den Werken beider
eine Abteilung ist  Methode ist Liebeserotik
Sehnsucht nach einer erotischen
Vollendung mit Gott, also hier eine erste
Passage von High-Schädigung aus ihren
Schriften, also ist dies ein gutes Beispiel für
die intensive Erotik, mit der
sie die Beziehung beschreibt, dass sie eine
Art Mystikerin in Bezug auf Gott ist  seht seinen
mund uns nahe gebracht den zu küssen
der es wünscht seine arme sind
ausgestreckt wer umarmt werden will darf
sich in sie werfen ja um es kurz zu sagen
gott hat sich uns in der
zeit zugeneigt alles was wir von ihm haben und wünschen
können und  alles, was wir verstehen können, so
viel wir wollen und wie wir wollen
, damit er bei uns in Liebe
und Erfüllung sein kann, so weit haben wir nur eine
Art vielleicht irgendwie vorhersehbarer Idee,
die Sie wieder wollen  Ich erwarte
von jemandem, der sich Gott verpflichtet hat,
recht
viel Energie und Interessen, anstatt sie auf einen
Menschen zu richten, konzentriert sie sie auf Gott,
aber eigentlich ist das, was hier vor sich geht,
viel selbstbewusster und
literarischer als das und  Der Grund, warum ich das sage
, ist, dass HUD davon
und das gilt auch für Methyls.
Beide spielen irgendwie mit
einer Reihe von literarischen Konventionen herum
, die ihrem Publikum
aus der Tradition dessen, was wir heute
höfische Liebe nennen, vertraut waren  Wenn
Sie also jemals mittelalterliche Literatur zitiert haben,
bin ich sicher, dass Sie darauf gestoßen sind,
wäre ein wirklich berühmtes Beispiel ein
langes Gedicht, das nach ihnen
am Ende des 13. Jahrhunderts von jemandem
namens Shonda Moon geschrieben wurde, der genannt wird
Romanze der Rose ist eigentlich die
Vervollständigung eines kürzeren Gedichts,
das zu Beginn des 13.
Jahrhunderts geschrieben wurde, und in Romanze der Rose haben
wir diese lange Beschreibung eines Liebhabers
, der sich verzehrt  Weg für eine Geliebte, die
in diesem Fall keine Frau, sondern eine Rose ist, und
es ist die Geschichte seines langen qualvollen
Versuchs, mit dieser Rose
seine Liebe zu ihr zu verführen und zu vollenden, und das ist
typisch für diese höfischen Liebeswerke
natürlich die meisten von ihnen  sind bei weitem nicht so
spektakulär und lang, aber
es gibt viele, viele Gedichte
, die um diese Zeit entstanden sind,
die mit diesen Konventionen spielen
und eine ganze Reihe
von Klischees entwickelt haben, die man fast
mit dieser Höflichkeit assoziieren würde  Liebe
belesen
und im Kern ist es tatsächlich diese
Vorstellung eines sehnsüchtigen Liebhabers, der unter
großen Qualen leidet, weil er und wir normalerweise
er immer er er er seine Geliebte nicht erreichen kann
er irgendwie von ihr entfernt ist
sie vielleicht nicht einmal weiß, dass er existiert und das
ist  was ihm unglaubliche Qualen bereitet, und
vielleicht singt er ein Klagelied
darüber, und Sie können sehen, wie
ausdrücklich aus seinen Anspielungen darauf in
diesem nächsten Zitat in Glückseligkeit immer etwas
Gutes für das Herz des th bleibt  Der
höfische Liebhaber, das ist das Gesetz der
Ritterlichkeit, die einzige Ruhe eines solchen Herzens
besteht darin, sein Äußerstes für seinen
Geliebten zu tun und ihm
angesichts seiner Erhabenheit Liebe und Ehre zu erweisen, bis er ihm
edle Dienste als unentgeltliches Geschenk anbietet  aber
weil sie sich selbst jederzeit lieben und
zufrieden sind und genug bezahlen, ist dies
etwas,
das den Lesern eigentlich sehr vertraut gewesen wäre,
wenn sie auf ihre höfischen
Liebeslieder und Literatur aufmerksam geworden wären, hätten
sie diese Idee erkannt, der Sie
sich widmen sollten  die Geliebte um der
Liebe willen aus keinem anderen Grund und
dann solltest du dich als eine Art
Dauerleidenden sehen, vielleicht sogar
verzweifelt, weil du denkst, dass du
deine Geliebte nie erreichen wirst, das
wäre alles sehr vertraut, was
weniger vertraut wäre  Ein paar Dinge
zuerst, vielleicht um zu sagen, dass
sie offensichtlich eine Frau ist, also haben wir hier keinen
männlichen Ritter, der sich zum Beispiel nach
einer Dame sehnt, wie Sie es oft
in Fr  ench höfische Liebeslieder oder
übrigens in Chaucer, wer ist ein weiterer Autor,
der mit diesen höfischen und
höfischen Liebeskonventionen herumspielt?
er ist der Geliebte und sie ist
verzweifelt, weil sie ihn irgendwie nicht bekommen kann,
und hier können Sie vielleicht schon
sehen, wie dies ein
wirklich großartiges Beispiel für eine Welle für einen
mystischen Autor ist, um genau
die philosophische Idee auszudrücken, über die ich gesprochen
habe  Beginn des Vortrags, also
erinnern Sie sich an die philosophische Idee, dass
Gott irgendwie etwas ist, zu dem wir
keinen Zugang haben, weil er
metaphysisch außerhalb unserer Welt ist, weil
er erkenntnistheoretisch ist
ihn, weil die
Sprache nicht auf ihn zutrifft, unser normales
Denken trifft auf ihn nicht zu und so weiter,
und was wir also brauchen, ist ein anderer Weg
, um zu ihm zu gelangen, und was sie
hier beschreibt, ist eigentlich der Zustand  man findet
sich wieder, wenn man das versäumt hat
, also befindet man sich in einer Art Verzweiflung, einem
Zustand, der dem
emotionalen Zustand eines menschlichen Liebhabers gleicht, der
seine Geliebte nicht hat, aber sie ist
dort, wo eine Geschlechtsumkehr vor sich geht,
also bin ich das  Ich finde das sehr interessant, also wird sie als
Nächstes darüber
nachdenken, was passiert, wenn die
Beziehung zu Gott tatsächlich vollendet ist,
und hier haben wir eine sehr
traditionelle mystische Idee, die Sie
bis zu einem gewissen Grad auch in uns aufgenommen haben, aber
in vielen Fällen auftaucht  mittelalterliche Mystiker und dies ist
die Idee, dass, solange Sie
sich von Gott unterscheiden, Sie
sich von Penny entfremdet oder entfernt sind.
Sie wollen also nicht dorthin gelangen, wo Sie
ihn sehen können, sondern dorthin, wo Sie
verschwinden oder dahinschmelzen  und nichts als
Gott bleibt, und das macht Sinn,
denn wenn das Problem darin besteht, dass Sie hier
unten sind und er hier oben und er so
transzendent und überlegen ist, dass Sie
diesen Übergang nicht schaffen können, wäre der beste Weg, um
zu Gott zu gelangen, zu irgendetwas  Verlassen Sie das
Reich, in dem Sie sich selbst finden, das
minderwertige erschaffene Reich, damit Sie
Metaphern des Mystischen haben, das dahinschmilzt
oder vernichtet und mit Gott vereint wird.
Hier ist ein sehr gutes Beispiel,
indem sie diese traditionelle mystische
Metapher verwendet, sagt sie, ich blieb in einem
Vergehen in meinem  Geliebte, so dass ich
ganz in ihm verschmolz und
nichts mehr von mir übrig blieb,
also mag das, wie ich schon sagte, in gewisser Weise eine ziemlich
vertraute Idee und Mystik sein, aber sie sieht
eine Art brillante Art
, das mit dem Thema zu verbinden, das wir waren  Ich spreche nur
von der Art der Verzweiflung,
verliebt zu sein, weil ihre Idee in gewisser Weise
sogar fair wäre, zu sagen, dass
ich das Zentrum besucht habe, und irgendwie juckt ihre
zentrale Idee, dass Sie, wenn Sie
genug verzweifeln, sich Ihrem Leiden hingeben
genug hast oder dich diesem
verzweifelten, sehnsüchtigen Leiden hingibst, dann
wirst du so ausgelöscht
und so erniedrigt, dass du eins
mit Gott wirst oder dich zumindest
mit deiner eigenen Liebe identifizierst  Für Gott, was ist das
Beste, was Sie als Mystiker tun können, und hier ist eine
großartige Passage aus einer ihrer Kolumnen,
in der sie meiner Meinung nach diese Idee vermittelt
, dass wir noch mehr über Liebe sagen können. Ihr
Reichtum ist ihr Mangel an allem, was
ihre wahre Treue hervorbringt  unsere
Schuld ihr höchstes Wesen ertränkt uns im
Tod ihr großer Reichtum beschert Armut
ihre Großzügigkeit erweist sich als unser Bankrott
für zärtliche Pflege und weitet unsere Wunden die
Verbindung mit ihr bringt den Tod über
und über ihren Tisch ist Hunger ihre
Wissenskraft so meine ich denke an
Auf den ersten Blick mag das nur wie ein
Haufen Paradoxe aussehen, genau wie Liebe,
Wissen ist Fehler, wenn sie den
Tisch mit einem Bankett gedeckt hat, das Hunger ist, aber
das Paradox hat einen Punkt, der darin besteht, dass
sie eine Art Selbstverleugnung des
Liebhabers / Mystikers ist  genau darauf abzielte,
das Selbst bis zu dem Punkt zu eliminieren, an
dem die Mystikerin für Gott nicht mehr
von ihr
zu unterscheiden ist, und das soll ein
Weg sein, zu Gott zu gelangen, und so können
Sie jetzt vielleicht sehen, was ich mit Nein meinte  Wenn Sie sagen,
dass dies in gewisser Weise effektiv ist,
dreht sich alles um Emotionen, es geht um Liebe, und
es ist sehr konkret, aber es ist auch in
gewisser Weise kontemplativ, wenn Sie
diese Sprache verwenden möchten, denn hier gibt es eine Art
Theorie darüber, wie eine mystische Vereinigung
funktioniert  Die Theorie besagt, dass, wenn Sie
das Selbst eliminieren und das einzige, was
übrig bleibt, Verlangen oder Liebe ist, wenn
Sie Gott am nächsten kommen, wenn Sie nicht mit ihm identisch sind
, etwas anderes, was es wert
ist, darüber gesagt zu werden, dass es eine typisch
christliche Denkweise über die
Vereinigung mit mystischem Bewusstsein ist  Gott, denn indem sie
das Leiden so sehr betont,
vergleicht sie sich natürlich mit Christus
, der am Kreuz gelitten hat, um uns
von unseren Sünden zu befreien, also wäre der Gedanke hier,
dass ich, gerade als Gott ein Mensch wurde und
bereit war, er zu sein, eine große Eieranie gemacht habe
Opfer für uns, also muss die Mystikerin
irgendwie mit ihrer eigenen inneren
Qual und ihrem Leiden in Kontakt kommen, um
irgendwie zu Gott zurückzukehren, also könnte man sich
das sogar als was das Neo vorstellen  Ebene
würde dies Prozession und Rückkehr nennen, also
geht Gott hinaus in die Schöpfung, indem er ein
Mensch wird, und dann muss die Schöpfung
durch den gleichen Mechanismus
durch den Mechanismus des Leidens zu Gott zurückkehren, also
hier ist eine weitere Passage von Heidi,
die meiner Meinung nach wirklich klar macht, wie
Ihr eigenes mystisches Verfahren
soll eng mit der Geschichte von
Christus und seinem Leiden verbunden sein, also
spricht sie hier im Namen Gottes und sie
sagt, wenn Sie wie ich und meine Menschlichkeit sein möchten, möchten
Sie mich
ganz in meiner Göttlichkeit besitzen  und mein
Menschlichkeitsrecht, das ist Christus, der sowohl Gott als auch
Mensch ist, du wirst dir wünschen, arm und
elend zu sein und von allen Menschen verachtet zu werden, und
Kummer wird dir süßer schmecken als
alle irdischen Freuden, lass sie auf keinen Fall
in dir sitzen, denn sie werden jenseits der menschlichen
Natur sein  zu tragen, wenn du der
Liebe auf Drängen deiner edlen Natur folgen willst,
die dich dazu bringt, mich in meiner Gesamtheit zu begehren
, so werden Ellie und
du, unter Menschen zu leben, und du
wirst so de sein  verärgert und so unglücklich, dass
du nicht weißt, wo du für eine
einzige Nacht übernachten sollst, und alle Personen werden
von dir abfallen und dich verlassen,
und hier ist eine weitere Passage,
die die Idee von Leiden und Schmerz mit der
Idee von Liebe verbindet, wenn du dich dem Erhabenen nähern willst
zu lieben und ihren Weg perfekt zu lernen,
musst du immer mit brennendem Eifer
nach neuen Leiden suchen, um der Liebe willen wird er
alle Schmerzen mit Liebe zurückzahlen, also
gibt es die Idee, dass
du paradoxerweise die Glückseligkeit der Vereinigung mit Gott hast, indem du absichtlich Qualen erleidest und Schmerzen
erleidest,
denn wie ich sage  Sobald du
alle Unterschiede zwischen dir
und Gott beseitigt hast durch diese Art von erbärmlicher
Armut des Geistes, wie sie es ausdrücken könnte,
gibt es nichts mehr, was
dich von Gott entfernen
könnte
Ich meine, das ist keine Empfehlung,
also sollten Sie Folgendes versuchen, wenn Sie
eine mystische Erfahrung von Gott machen wollen,
indem Sie einfach so viel emotionale Qual wie
möglich haben und dann hüpfen  Dass das
dein Selbstgefühl bis zu dem Punkt zerstört, an dem
Gott dich besucht, ich mache es irgendwie klein
, was ich vielleicht nicht tun sollte, aber
das ist okay, denn das ist nicht wirklich das,
was sie sagt, sie ist sowieso genau
wie Hildegard, was sie tut  ein
besonderer Anspruch auf oder eine Art
privilegierter Anspruch auf Zugang zu Gott als
etwas, das jeder haben kann, und
das wird in ihren Visionen deutlicher, so dass
ihre Visionen oft erzählen, dass sie bei einem
religiösen Anlass wie Ostern
oder ein anderer Feiertag sind  wurde
plötzlich von einer Art Vision heimgesucht und sie
beschreibt die Vision und erklärt
sie vielleicht ein wenig und das ist es, was man bekommt,
und diese Visionen sind sehr kurzer
Text, sie sind sehr lebhaft, sie sind
nicht annähernd so  Artikuliert erklärt
, wie gehaltene
Wachen sind, wie ich zuvor sagte, und eines
der Dinge, die sie wirklich betont,
und dies ist wieder eine andere
Dimension ihrer Verwendung des Courtney
Love-Themas, ist, dass sie
zwischen Kontakten hin und her geht w  mit Gott, der
in diesen Visionen besteht und dann
von Gott entfernt wird, so dass sie irgendwie von ihm abfällt,
Schmerzen hat, Qualen erleidet,
Verzweiflung hat, und dann bekommt sie plötzlich diese
Momente mystischer Einsicht, die Vision,
und dann fällt sie wieder weg und in gewisser
Weise ich  Ich denke, man könnte sagen, dass es ihr
Gefühl des Leidens ist, dass sie
diese Momente intensiver Glückseligkeit erlebt hat.
Ob sie tatsächlich
von realen Erfahrungen berichtet, die sie hatte, können wir nicht sagen,
der Punkt daran ist, dass es
fast egal ist, was sie gibt
Dies ist eine Art literarische
Darstellung dessen, wie es wäre, in
mystische Erfahrungen ein- und auszugehen, also ist es nicht
so, dass sich die Mystiker einfach dauerhaft
mit Gott vereinen, sondern es ist diese
Absicht und intensive, eine extrem
emotionale Oszillation zwischen Vereinigung und
Trennung, also hier ist eine  Stelle, die
das sehr schön zum Ausdruck bringt, als ich am
Pfingstsonntag den Heiligen Geist
so empfing, dass ich den ganzen
Willen der Liebe und alles und jeden verstand  Die
Weisen dieses Willens der Himmel und der
himmlischen Dinge und die ganze Vollkommenheit
der vollkommenen Gerechtigkeit und alle
Mängel der Verlorenen und im Hinblick
auf alles sah ich den Willen, in dem sie
damals entweder wahr oder falsch waren, und
seitdem ich  Ich habe in gleicher Weise
die Liebe aller Menschen empfunden, die ich
damals gesehen habe, und ich
habe alle Sprachen verstanden,
die auf zweiundsiebzig Arten gesprochen werden. Die
Vielfalt all dieser Dinge war
mir verborgen und ist daher
verschwunden  Linie ist wirklich der entscheidende Punkt, also
sieht sie all diese Dinge und dann ist es einfach
weg und ich meine, ich habe vorher gesagt, dass wir
weibliche Mystiker nicht
als rein passiv betrachten sollten, und ich denke, das ist
aus der Höhe klar, weil
es offensichtlich ein sehr gibt
aktiver Prozess von intensiver Liebe und
Sehnsucht, aber es hat auch etwas
Passives, denn wirklich
alles, was der Liebende tun kann, ist einfach zu warten und zu
hoffen, den Geliebten zu sehen, was wiederum ein
sehr bekannter Ausdruck ist  Lügner aus der
höfischen Liebesliteratur Eine andere Sache
, die ich erwähnen sollte, bevor wir
kurz zum Metal übergehen, ist das HUD, das
noch eine andere Konvention verwendet, die wir aus
dieser Literatur kennen, und wir sehen es sehr stark
in der Romantik der Rose, die die
Idee ist  bestimmte Arten von
Phänomenen und das Leben der Liebe als
Personifizierungen zu behandeln, so trifft man zum Beispiel in der
Romanze der Rose all diese
Charaktere und hält Reden, und es
werden Charaktere wie Eifersucht oder Lust oder
Verleumdung sein, und diese Charaktere werden aufstehen
und machen  Reden an den Liebhaber,
der diese Art von Merkmal des
verführerischen Lebens darstellt, und ähnlich haben Sie
hier in vielen Visionen einen Teil von uns, der
nicht nur Gott sieht, sondern auch andere
Charaktere, einschließlich des Charakters der
Vernunft und der Tugenden und so weiter
etwas, das wir sehen  sah auch zu einem gewissen
Grad und die Hildegard, also lassen Sie mich
Ihnen nur eine Passage geben, die ein schönes
Beispiel dafür ist, dass sie eine Frau sieht,
die ein Kleid trägt, das mit Augen
und t bedeckt ist  Die Frau sagt, weißt du, wer ich bin,
und sie sagt zu ihr, ja, lange
genug hast du mir Leid und Schmerz zugefügt,
du bist die Vernunft meiner Seele, und
das sind die Beamten meines eigenen
Haushalts, mit denen du in solchem Rückgratstil durch die Welt gehst
das sind drei Frauen
, die mit Vernunft zusammen sind als ihre Art
von begleitenden Mägden der Trompeter
ist meine heilige Angst wurde geprüft meine
Vollkommenheit in allem, was zum
Leben der Liebe gehört das zweite Mädchen ist die
Unterscheidung zwischen dir und der Liebe und sie
hatte versucht, die der Liebe zu unterscheiden  Wille und
Lust aus deinem die dritte Bedeutung ist
Weisheit, durch die ich
deine Macht in deinen Werken anerkannt habe, wenn du dich
von der Liebe leiten ließst
und durch die ich erkennen gelernt habe, dass
Gott allein Gott ist und alle Dinge als Gott
in Gottes Erkenntnis und jedem  So etwas wie Gott,
wenn ich im Geiste mit Gott vereint bin,
welche Neuigkeiten bringst du mir, als die
Vernunft nicht zu mir gesprochen hatte, befahl sie
mir, die ganze Zahl meiner Gesellschaft anzuerkennen,
und ich tat es dann  Sie wurde
mir untertan und ich verließ sie, aber die Liebe
kam und umarmte mich und ich kam aus
dem Geist und blieb bis spät in den
Tag betrunken von unsäglichen Wundern, also
gebe ich dir das teilweise nur,
um dir eine Art von Wiederholung zu geben  Geschmack
der Art und Weise, wie sie diese
literarischen Tropen und Strategien übernimmt, aber ein
weiterer Grund, warum ich diese Passage auswähle, ist,
weil Sie diese Gegenüberstellung von
Vernunft und Liebe haben und sehen, dass sie
beide in das Leben des Mystikers verwickelt sind,
also Vernunft seiner Art  von den Mitteln, durch die
sie versucht herauszufinden, wie sie vielleicht
zu Gott kommen kann, und irgendwann
gibt sie einfach die Vernunft auf und gibt
sich der Liebe hin, was natürlich so ist, wie
wir den Weg zu Gott gesehen haben, den ich gehe, der ist
entdeckt, also schauen wir uns jetzt
endlich Hildegard Heloise und heißes Bild
an. Schauen wir uns endlich eine mittelalterliche Autorin an,
deren Name nicht mit H beginnt, namens
Amex von Magdeburg, die in vielerlei Hinsicht
ähnlich ist und wie gesagt
Mitte des 13. Jahrhunderts lebte und  schrieb  auf deutsch
nicht lateinisch und auch nicht niederländisch also
schrieb sie dieses werk vom fließenden licht auf
, das gott hatte, in dem sie wieder
sehr gerne wie zu sehr
einige der themen der liebe übernimmt das wort, das
hier bei beiden autoren oft verwendet wird
Minute manchmal verwenden die Leute den Ausdruck
Minute on, also Psalmen der Liebe, um zu beschreiben,
was sie tun, und dies wäre auch
das Wort in ihrer höfischen Liebesliteratur gewesen.
Diese Sprachen übernehmen also gewissermaßen
das, was sie hier tun
einen bestehenden Diskurs über
Liebe
darin, und sie theoretisieren und
wenden ihn auf die mystische Vereinigung mit Gott an
, das ist die grundlegende Idee, und wie Sie
vielleicht schon bemerkt haben, können Sie
sehen, dass dies in vielerlei Hinsicht
potenziell beunruhigend für ein mittelalterliches
Publikum sein könnte, richtig  Schade, besonders ein männliches
mittelalterliches Publikum, so dass Sie die Vorstellung
eines privilegierten Zugangs zu Gott haben, Sie haben die
Vorstellung einer Frau, die an erster
Stelle und vielleicht auf die beunruhigendste Weise schreibt, und
das ist etwas, das oft besorgniserregend ist
Wenn man im Mittelalter über Mystiker gesprochen hat, hat
man die Vorstellung, dass die
Vollendung der Beziehung zwischen
Gott und der Frau erstens
sexuell beschrieben wird, was ziemlich
provokativ sein könnte, und zweitens scheint
es um das zu gehen, was wir gesehen haben, um diese
Verschmelzung zu beheben  weg von dem Selbst, die
Auslöschung des Selbst, das mit
Gott verschmilzt wie Eis mit warmem Wasser oder
so etwas und diese Vorstellung, dass
du irgendwie Gott werden könntest,
indem du dich so weit gründest,
dass nichts mehr von dir übrig wäre, was
dich trennen würde  von Gott ist das natürlich
theologisch sehr problematisch, denn
wenn wir auf das ursprüngliche Problem zurückgehen,
das war, dass Gott der Schöpfung überlegen war, ist
er unendlich besser. Jetzt kommen diese Mystiker daher
, Frauen, um hochzufahren, und sagen,
sicher, das ist das Problem,
aber die Lösung ist, dass Sie sortieren können  sich
selbst so weit auf nichts zu reduzieren,
dass man mit Gott identisch
wird, das ist alles sehr herausfordernd für das
mittelalterliche Publikum, und Nectow ist absolut
Ich bin mir dessen nur sehr bewusst und rede tatsächlich
in ihrem Buch darüber, also beginne ich einfach
mit meiner Lieblingspassage
aus dem Buch, in der sie sich
Sorgen über die Reaktion macht, die ihr Buch
hervorrufen könnte, und hier ist, was sie sagt, ich
wurde davor gewarnt, dies zu schreiben
Buchleute sagten, wenn ich nicht aufpassen würde
, könnte es verbrannt werden, und als Gott
sich meiner freudlosen Seele offenbarte, hielt er dieses
Buch in seiner rechten Hand und sagte, mein Lieber,
sei nicht übermäßig beunruhigt, niemand
kann die Wahrheit verbrennen, damit sie jemand nimmt
Dieses Buch aus meiner Hand muss
mächtiger sein als ich.
Das Buch ist dreifach, hat drei Teile
wie die Dreifaltigkeit
und stellt mich allein dar, also zweifle nicht an
dir, also mag ich diese Zeile wirklich, die
Wahrheit kann nicht verbrannt werden und es zeigt auf eine
Weise, wie  selbstbewusst ist sie, also gibt es eine
andere Zeile in dem Buch, wo sie
sich mit Scholastikern vergleicht, also mit den
Männern an den Universitäten, und sie sagt im
Grunde gut, ich bin KEIN Gelehrter,
und sie sagt, aber ich bin
diesen Schol tatsächlich weit voraus  Astische Männer in Bezug
auf meine Beziehung zu Gott, also haben Sie
wieder ein Liebeserrata-System, das als eine
Art alternativer Weg zu Gott und in
Mack gegeben wird. Wenn also irgendetwas noch offener ist
als ein AA de vich, hier ist ein Beispiel
von unserer Art  Autismus, den sie
in ihrem Buch verwendet, wenn Ihr Ostertag kommt
und Ihr Körper den Todesstoß erhält,
werde ich Sie fest umarmen und
Sie vollständig durchdringen und Sie aus Ihrem
Körper stehlen und Sie Ihrem Liebhaber übergeben
, das ist also eine wirklich intensive
Passage  unsere effektive
Vorstellung des Todes, physischer Tod als
scheinbar sexuelle Vereinigung, also die
Möglichkeit für die Geliebte,
endlich mit dem Liebhaber zusammenzukommen oder
umgekehrt,
und natürlich eine Art Paradoxon,
die sich dort umkehrte, weil es
nichts Physischeres und Körperlicheres gibt als
Sex, und sie benutzt Sex  Als Metapher
für das, was passiert, wenn man seinen Körper verliert, ist
dies eine clevere Art von Paradoxon oder
Umkehrung, von der wir
auch ein seltsames Bild gesehen haben, das eigentlich ziemlich
typisch ist  Ich liebe sie nicht nur in dem Sinne,
dass ihr ein Paradox zugrunde liegt
, sondern auch in dem Sinne, dass sie
die physische Welt und die kreative
Welt oft als etwas darstellt, das man
ablehnen oder von dem man wegkommen muss, um sich ihm
anzunähern  Gott gibt es eine andere
Dimension dieser Idee
, sich selbst auf Selbstverleugnung und
Selbstverleugnung zu stützen
, um die Vereinigung mit Gott zu erreichen, aber
ihr Fokus liegt sehr stark auf einer Art
Verachtung der Dinge in der
kreativen Welt, die ein gutes Beispiel dafür war  Gott
hat mich nie allein geführt und mich zu
solch geistlicher Süße, zu solch heiligem
Wissen und zu solch unbeschreiblichem Wunder gebracht,
dass irdische Dinge für mich keinen Nutzen hatten,
und hier ist wieder eine andere Passage, Herr, ich
wohne in einem Land namens Exil, das
diese Welt umsonst ist  kann
mich trösten oder mich aufmuntern, außer dem Leiden an
diesem Ort. Ich habe ein Haus, es heißt
voller Schmerz. Das ist das Haus, wo
meine Seele gefangen liegt
Die grundsätzlich platonische Einstellung
zum Körper zum Körper, die physische Welt
im Allgemeinen ist genau das, was
Sie von der Vereinigung mit der spirituellen Realität
abhält, die hier nicht die
Welt der Formen sein wird, wie im Spiel, sondern
Gott und hier ist  noch eine
Passage darüber, die ein Gedicht ist,
das in ihrem Buch erscheint, normalerweise liebe das
Nichts, du solltest etwas dafür einflehen,
du solltest allein stehen und
zu niemandem gehen, du solltest die Kranken heilen
und doch selbst nichts haben, du solltest
das Wasser des Leidens trinken  Wenn Sie
das Feuer der Liebe mit dem Anzünden der Tugend entzünden,
dann leben Sie in der Wahrheitswüste,
also gibt es viele
Passagen, die sehr stark mit
Anspielungen versehen sind, sodass Sie wahrscheinlich
die Anspielung auf das Leben Christi genau
wie das Heilen aufgegriffen haben  krank, die Idee
, in der Wüste zu leben, ist eine Anspielung auf
die asketische Tradition. Eigentlich
könnte es eine Anspielung darauf sein, dass Christus
in die Wüste geht, aber ich für mich ist es auch
duftend o  In der Tradition der Asketen,
die in der Spätantike in die
Wüste gingen, um als klösterliche Gemeinschaft
oder sogar allein zu leben, um einfach
zu versuchen, Gott in der Wildnis zu finden, und dies
tut sie in einer
Art spirituellem Set ironischerweise die B  Die Schlüsselbewegung
, der diese Frauen
angehören, ist tatsächlich weniger abgeschieden und
vom Rest der Welt abgeschnitten als echte
Nonnen, die versuchen, nicht gefangen zu sein, die
sich absichtlich in
ihrem Vertrauen für uns zurückgezogen haben, das beginnt, wie ich
sagte, tatsächlich mit dem Austausch zu beginnen
Außenwelt, aber trotzdem gibt es
sehr viel dieses Treiben
, sich von der Welt zu entfernen
, sich nur Gott hinzugeben und
alles andere zu ignorieren, aber nur als ein Abseits davon wird
dies nicht als etwas dargestellt, das
man einfach so tun kann, wie es ist  sehr
schwierig und der Weg zur mystischen Vereinigung
mit Gott wird als
quälend schwierig angesehen, viel Leid mit sich zu bringen
und etwas zu tun, das sie wirklich mit FEMA
verbindet i  s hier ist etwas, was sie
in der deutschen Folklore heute Abend nennt, was so viel
wie Entfremdung bedeutet, also wie
radikale Entfernung von Gott und vielleicht
könnte man es sogar als eine Art
Entfremdung betrachten,
also ist diese Entfremdung oder Entfremdung von
Gott der Zustand, in dem sich die Mystikerin
befindet  sich selbst, wenn sie es nicht schafft,
diese Momente der Klarheit zu erreichen, diese
Momente der Vereinigung, also ist es wieder sehr
ähnlich, wie zu viel in die
visionäre Vereinigung mit Gott ein- und ausgeht, also lass mich
dir nur eine letzte Passage vorlesen, die
von mir kommt  Braut
Gottes, als sie im versiegelten
Schatzhaus der Heiligen Dreifaltigkeit eingeschlossen war, steh
auf und verlass mich alle Kreaturen, du hast
mir Schmerzen zugefügt und kannst mich nicht trösten.
Die Kreatur sagte, warum die Braut sagte, meine
Geliebte habe mich verlassen, während ich schlief,
nachdem ich gefallen war  eingeschlafen mit ihm
kann diese schöne Welt und all die
guten Dinge darin nicht trösten, du weißt, ich sehe
es an der Schlange der Falschheit
, die sich durch alle Begierden hindurcharbeitet  von
dieser Welt, das ist eine großartige Passage und auf
eigentlich, weil es uns
mehrere der Themen zusammenbringt, die wir im
Kampf gesehen haben, und auch einen hohen Schaden, so dass wir
die Ablehnung der guten Dinge dieser
Welt haben, damit sie ihr keinen Trost bieten können,
weil  Sie ist verzweifelt darüber, Gott verloren zu haben,
nachdem sie auf eine höchst sexualisierte Weise mit Gott zusammen war,
als sie
mit ihm schlief und sein Name
sich mit ihm verband, so dass diese Vorstellung von
sexueller Vereinigung entsteht,
wenn man es vielleicht nicht erwartet und
sicherlich  kann nicht auf Abruf kommen,
weil der Geliebte für dich unerreichbar ist
, das ist die Grundidee, die
ihre Arbeit antreibt, und es ist
sehr emotional, das wollen wir nicht leugnen
, aber wie ich schon mehrfach gesagt habe, ist
es auch sehr  selbstbewusst in gewisser
Weise sehr spielerisch, richtig, sie
wissen, dass Sie die Literatur kennen, auf die
sie zurückgreifen, sie verwenden sogar das
technische Vokabular dieser Literatur
wie das Wort dürfen sie die Tropen
dieser Literatur verwenden l  Wie die Verwendung von
Personifikationen, so wie die Tugenden oder die
Vernunft, die als Charaktere erscheinen und
mit ihnen sprechen, speisen sie auch
diese längere Tradition, die
auf Hildegard und andere Autoren zurückgeht
, über Visionen zu berichten und Ihnen dann
einen Bericht darüber zu geben, so waren diese  Ich
würde Frauen vorschlagen, die sehr viel
Kontrolle über das hatten, was sie taten, und die
Idee der Mystikerinnen, da Sie
passive Empfänger dieser erstaunlichen
Visionen sind, von denen sie einfach nicht wussten, was sie
damit anfangen sollten und nicht wussten, wie sie sie
verstehen sollten  Für männliche Leser
zu interpretieren, ist das sehr weit von dem entfernt, was
diese beiden Frauen tun, und auch wenn
sie manchmal irgendwie der Wut
schon die Karte spielen, wie wenn Mac Thoth sagt,
ich bin kein gelehrter Mann, wissen Sie, dass ich
nur eine einfache Frau bin  So wie
Hildegard es auch gemacht hat Ich denke, es ist klar
, dass das auch Teil eines literarischen Spiels ist,
es ist alles Teil eines Anspruchs,
wie den Anspruch auf eine Autorität zu erheben,
um auf eine Weise über mystische Einheit zu sprechen, wie
es niemand tut  tun können, und sie verwenden
eine ganze Batterie verschiedener literaturphilosophischer
Techniken, um
das
als solches Kreuz hinzubekommen, also ist das genug für
heute,
also haben wir über den Wasserstoffhals gesprochen, bis
wir das nächste Mal zu
jemandem übergehen, der  machte sich nicht nur Sorgen, dass sie
wegen einer Sache Ärger bekommen könnte, während
sie schrieb, wer tatsächlich mehr
als nur ein bisschen Ärger bekam, sie wurde
tatsächlich für ihre Schriften und ihre Ideen hingerichtet,
und das sind Marguerite-Dichter,
die bis zum Beginn von lebten  im 14.
Jahrhundert, als sie in Paris hingerichtet wurde,
damit wir die Erbin ihrer Geschichte
bei der nächsten Vorlesung begleiten können,
danke, dass Sie diesmal mitgekommen sind